he dejado los últimos 10 años de mi vida
a rediseñar mi vida y hoy tengo 10
minutos para contarte por qué deberías
rediseñar la tuya porque es importante
que hay que es tiempo todos los días de
tu vida a conocerte profundamente y
porque vivimos el mejor momento para
hacerlo si eres de los que cree que se
conoce profundamente y que tú diseñaste
tu vida te va a contar porque yo creo
que no los estudios que hemos hecho y
los datos que hemos recolectado en los
últimos años así lo demuestran la razón
principal por la cual el 99% de las
personas queremos cambiar algo en
nuestra vida y no podemos es porque
pensamos que somos autónomos pero el
último no lo somos pongas empezar en una
cosa en la vida todo está diseñado tu
ropa el dispositivo por el que estás
viendo o escuchando esta charla la cama
donde duermes los cubiertos con los que
comes en fin mira a tu alrededor y verás
que todo ha sido diseñado pero qué pasa
si te miras a ti mismo en el espejo
cuantas veces piensas en hacer un diseño
consciente de cómo eres o de cómo
quieres ser o más importante cómo
quieres sentirte frente a cualquier cosa
que te suceda
hay una cosa hermosa en la vida y es el
poder de nuestra mente resulta que
puedes diseñar cómo quieres ser qué
quieres hacer cómo te quieres sentir
cómo te quieres comportar y qué tipo de
pensamientos quieres tener y en este
momento pues te puede sonar lógico pero
te puedes preguntar pero por qué no lo
hacemos entonces porque el
autoconocimiento la base para diseñar
nuestra vida de manera consciente no ha
estado presente en el currículo nuestras
vidas y porque vivimos de creencias
arraigadas en el pasado no sabemos de
dónde viene lo que pensamos ni de dónde
o por que reaccionamos cómo lo hacemos
resulta que el subconsciente maneja
entre el 95 y el 99 por ciento de lo que
pensamos sentimos decimos y hacemos a lo
largo del día el proceso consciente es
solamente entre el 5 y el 1 por ciento
imagínense si estamos programados hasta
el 99% de nuestro tiempo lo que está
programado en tu subconsciente es un
conjunto de situaciones experiencias
historias y verdades de otros heredadas
y repetidas por generaciones atrás que
tú tomaste como ciertas
condicionamientos de la cultura en la
que creciste y de las
que te educaron también piensa en una
cosa será nacido en chino con tus mismos
padres serías la misma persona tendrías
las mismas creencias no cierto
ese es el condicionamiento cultural y si
eres nacido en el mismo sitio en el que
naciste pero con padres diferentes
tampoco es cierto ese es el
condicionamiento paternal o maternal
somos lo que creemos
por ejemplo miren esta imagen muy simple
piensa en que ves que ves en esta imagen
a modo general
en los trabajos que hemos hecho nueve de
cada diez personas dice que ve un ciervo
cruzando una carretera y no está mal
pero si alguien tiene una educación
ambientalista que crees que respondería
ve en una carretera cruzando un bosque
porque primero estuvo el bosque que es
el espacio natural del ciervo la
pregunta es alguno de los dos está mal
no pero miren una cosa un estímulo
exterior es decir la información que
está en la foto y dos verdades y ninguna
está equivocada entonces la respuesta
depende de tu educación que se convirtió
en tu creencia resulta que no vivimos a
la altura de nuestras capacidades
vivimos a la altura de nuestras
creencias les cuento brevemente cómo
funciona algo que se llama la acción
mental que de cierta forma explica cómo
guardamos la información en el
subconsciente y explica por qué
reaccionamos como reaccionamos miren
esta otra foto y piensen que es lo
primero que sienten resulta que esta
foto que ven se presenta a ustedes como
un estímulo exterior entra en contacto
con la consciencia que es el primer paso
a través de los cinco sentidos y esa
información va rápidamente a la
el segundo paso que es como un archivo
donde se guardan todas nuestras
experiencias pasadas la educación ahí
también se alojan los paradigmas que
tenemos y condicionamientos mentales es
decir ahí están nuestras creencias en
este caso con esta foto ahí en esas
carpetas de la percepción vas a
encontrar tus experiencias pasadas con
el helado entonces si es una buena
experiencia lo siguiente el tercer paso
es que según la programación sientas una
sensación agradable o desagradable y
dependiendo de eso pasas a la cuarta
etapa de la acción mental que es la
reacción que puede existir de manera
física o verbal con la imagen del helado
que órganos sensoriales crees que
entraron en contacto con tu conciencia
muchos me dicen que la vista que está
bien y el gusto pero el gusto ya es una
reacción porque salí vamos por el
recuerdo de la sensación y ésta ha sido
disparada por la creencia que tienes del
helado si nunca has probado el helado
qué es lo que pasa en la puerta a los
sentidos es la misma cierto o sea entre
por acá pasa la percepción no encuentras
ningún registro por lo tanto no sabes
qué tipo de sensación causa entonces no
tienes cómo reaccionar
frente a ese estímulo pero qué pasa si
yo les digo lo siguiente y es que yo los
engañe y esto que está ahí no es la
imagen de una bola de lado
ustedes cómo reaccionarían como este
ejercicio lo he hecho ya cientos de
veces con miles de personas sé que la
mente retorcida de muchos de ustedes
como la mía estaba pensando en algo
bastante feo y desagradable y si no lo
estaban pensando pues seguro ahora si ya
lo estás haciendo lo importante este
ejercicio lo siguiente hace un minuto el
mismo estímulo exterior posiblemente los
hijos salió varios y wii que eliseo en
el lado en este momento y un minuto
después los hijos tenía una reacción
totalmente contraria y de disgusto así
que el estímulo exterior es el culpable
de cómo nos sentimos y de cómo
reaccionamos no en la vida siempre
estamos culpando el estímulo exterior y
lo que por eso no sucede lo que no
sucede es que mi jefe es que mi esposa
es que mis hijos es que el político de
turno etcétera etcétera no es el
estímulo exterior lo que te causa
angustia incertidumbre o miedo o
desdicha es lo que te sucede acá dentro
en la percepción frente a ese estímulo y
claro la foto si es un helado jamás
haría eso pero es un ejemplo perfecto de
cómo lo que pasa
define cómo nos vamos a sentir y es ahí
donde tenemos que entrar a reprogramar y
rediseñar lo que somos y lo que sentimos
por eso la habilidad de encontrarle
sentido en los tiempos más sentidos a la
vida si sean tiempos de injusticia de
hambre de incertidumbre o estrés extremo
es probablemente la creencia más
importante que debemos reprogramar en la
vida y encontrarle sentido a todo lo que
nos sucede es posible si reprogramamos
lo que nos han enseñado que es correcto
e incorrecto y rediseñamos nuestra
respuesta frente a eso
victor franklin reconocido entre otras
cosas por su libro el hombre en busca de
sentido que lo publicó justamente en
1946 después de haber sobrevivido en
campos de concentración nazi desde 1942
hasta 1945 el deseo lo siguiente
las fuerzas que están más allá de tu
control puede quitarte todo lo que
tienes pero hay una cosa que no tu
libertad para elegir cómo vas a
responder a esa situación ahí es donde
debemos reinventarnos y si te quiere
reinventar por ejemplo en tu hacer
también está bien y también hay un
proceso para eso pero que mejor que
reinventarse en cómo reaccionar frente a
cualquier estímulo exterior en
precisamente encontrarle sentido a todo
lo que nos sucede creo que es el momento
donde debes aprender a conocerte
profundamente para que todo el miedo y
la angustia que puedes estar viviendo no
dicten cómo te vas a sentido eso lo
decía esto la pregunta de más no está en
determinar si yo tengo razón con todo lo
que les he contado hoy o no está en
determinar qué tipo de persona quieres
ser y si tu respuesta frente al estímulo
exterior que estás viviendo o vas a
vivir es coherente con lo que tú quieres
ser entonces cómo quieres ser como te
quieres sentir el primer diseño de tu
vida no fue consciente aprovecha lo que
sucede en este momento como
para que el 2020 marquen tu camino en tu
travesía el año que empezaste a invertir
tiempo en ti mismo y te re diseñaste
pero esta vez desde la consciencia
estamos entrando en la era de abandonar
el ego que nos gobierna que nos gobierna
y conectarnos con la energía femenina
que tenemos todos los seres humanos y
esto no tiene nada que ver con la
sexualidad es una energía que nos
permite ser vulnerables para cambiar
porque pensar que ser vulnerable está
que el que ser vulnerable es malo es
simplemente una creencia más sumar por
ejemplo colaborar amar y agradecer es la
era enseñarnos y de que enseñemos a que
fracasar no es malo que no es malo que
colaborar es más importante que competir
es la era de despertar la conciencia y
dejar de mirar afuera para culpar a los
otros de lo que nos sucede y más bien
mirar adentro para entender por qué nos
sentimos así y si queremos mantener eso
o no es la era de encontrar nuestro
eslabón perdido en nuestro interior y
auto conocernos
y ya para cerrar y para pasar de la
palabra a la acción que para mí es tan
importante del conocimiento de la
sabiduría también inicia una nueva etapa
en mi vida durante años es más desde
1993 comencé a dejarme crecer el pelo y
siempre ha tenido el pelo largo aunque
hoy en día pues me creo como poco miren
estas fotos
por más de 25 años me identificado con
esta forma de verde así que voy a poner
a prueba una vez más mi autoconocimiento
con tal vez el ejercicio más difícil que
he hecho en mi vida me voy a raparme a
pelar es decir pueda cambiar mi aspecto
físico exterior para reafirmar lo que
realmente soy es decir lo que está acá
adentro que es donde yo los invito a
rediseñar se para encontrar su verdadera
esencia su voz interior y encontrarse de
nuevo con su verdadero ser es un
ejercicio muy estoico de practicar lo
que temo de verme diferente raro mal es
decir probar entre otros pues si sigo
poniendo atención a lo que piensan los
demás de mí y si eso me define como me
pasaba años atrás antes de rediseñar me
así es como se reinventa uno poniendo en
movimiento nuevas verdades que nos
confrontan con lo que somos actualmente
y nos acerquen más a nuestra verdadera
esencia entonces yo me pregunto
será que un nuevo estímulo exterior es
decir verme radicalmente diferente en el
espejo va a determinar lo que realmente
soy yo o cómo reaccionó frente a eso
será que mi ser va a cambiar por no
tener el pelo largo dejaré de
encontrarle sentido a la vida
si estoy totalmente pelado perderé toda
mi fuerza interior y mi pasión como le
pasó a sansón ustedes que creen
ya veremos
[Música]
y